Let's look at an interesting problem
based on the formula we have studied in
probability to find dice are thrown what
is the probability of getting a sum of 11 trust
me this is really
interesting to find dice are thrown simple
and we are asking the probability of getting
A sum of 11 let's call this dice d1 and the
other d2 each of those will show a number I need
you to think hard as to watch two numbers will give us
a sum of
11 well we can get a 5 on d1 and 6 on
d2 The sum equals 11 and there is another
combination that can give us 11 We can get 6
on d1 and 5 on
d2 Is there any other possibility in that we
get the sum as 11 No there is no other combination that means these are
the only two possibilities f  And six and
6s and f so probability of getting a sum
of 11 can be written as probability of
getting a 5 on d1 and 6 on d2 and getting a
6 on d1 and 5 on d2 don't get confused seeing this long
expression these are  Two
things we are talking about this is the
first event where we get a 5 on d1 and a 6 on
d2 and this is the second one in which we get
a 6 on d1 and a 5 on d2 we are using since it can be either this
And this it dozen matter as we get the
sum as 11 In each case let this b
event a and let this b event b so what we
essentially need to find is the
probability of a and b using the
formula we write it as p of a +  p of b -
p of a Intersection b Let me ask you an interesting
question Do you think these two
events can happen together that is impossible because if we
get a f on d1 and 6 on d2 you
can not get a 6 on d1 and a 5  on
d2 so the events a and b are mutually
exclusive probability of a intersection
b will be row as there is no chance that both can come together let's
zoom out a bit since this
is zero the formula becomes p of a p
of b now we  Just need to find these two
probabilities What is p of a Its this 5
on d1 and 6 on
d2 Notice that a and b both are considered two
events That two events for a and these two
for b Looking at events of a we can
That these two events are independent as
the outcome of one does not affect the other and
probability of each is
1/6 so p of a can be written as 1/6 *
1/6 this 1/6 is the probability of getting
a 5  On d1 and this 1/6 is the probability
of getting a 6 on d2 and sim similarly p
of can also be written as 1/6 in 1/6 that will give us
1/36 + 1/36 that is 2 by
36  Simplifying this fraction we can write it
as
1/1 So the probability of getting a sum of
11 at the throw of two dice is
1/1 There is a quicker way to solve
problems based on two dice which we will see later.